you mentioned the godfather good and
evil
that's your favorite movie yeah
what makes it great do you think the
characters the study of family
of justice of power what connects with
you oh oh i mean every one of those
themes
connects in the real
um and it connects in a cinematic way as
well
the difference i think with me and the
godfather was i've seen it during a
period of time when my father was absent
and
therefore
family structure and family values
was actually adopted
in my family
because of that you know
me and my brother devine
we actually
you know
took so much heed to that movie in our
family life
and
uh
we kind of
you know we kind of mimic that family in
this structure of somebody has to be the
leader of the family
even it was the younger michael was
younger than
sonny and fragile
you know i mean but he was worthy
and my brother devon is older than me my
brother king is older than me and it's
funny sometimes divine calls king
fragile and i know king wants the king
was actually he actually was he he could
beat our ass yeah
yeah uh but you're michael
yeah and not not by choice like
just by definition of that's what i am
you know i mean and
and uh it's just a blessing for me
to have my older sister my older
brothers uh and my younger brothers look
to me
as uh
just as a as a good light in the family
and like i said though that movie helped
us my sisters too we
you know the cool thing about my family
i don't know if i share this a lot
it's a big we all watch these movies
together
and so the a diagram pole fighter master
killer
father venus my family knows these
movies it's not just
i know them
right and then you extend it further my
friends know them right too
so there's a language
that we all can have
uh
that actually film has informed our
communication
so the godfather
you know which also is still
a fictitional story of something
but
since it was based in reality based on
something real and it was human it
wasn't so heightened
i think the purity of it
resonates and the privity of it is
something that resonates with me
you know
you got to be you got to plan ahead
you know he didn't want to deal with the
drugs
but
that time of business was upon him it's
like it's almost like
this is a tough one like sometime when
the muslim brothers come from the middle
east to america and they open up delhi's
right
they would sell him
and we would go in there and complain to
them and make them like they they just
get mad at us
but you know and that's as a kid but as
a man i'm like yo he's here to sell
now he still don't have to sell to him
like like vito corleone didn't want to
sell the drugs
okay he didn't have to do it he didn't
do it
and it cost him some bullets to
eventually somebody in the family ended
up doing it
you